this is the Trinity cube a problem we
designed to have three different answers
it can be collapsed into a
[Music]
cube but if you want the same color on
each face well then you need to solve it
a little bit
[Applause]
differently and here it is red yellow
blue purple green and black but the
third configuration is the wiliest you
have to create anamorphic images that
are skewed and stretched so as to only
appear normal when viewed from the side
if you are currently part of the
Curiosity box I am sending one of these
to you you'll get it next month if you
haven't joined yet it's not too late in
fact there are still ways to get our
daer Dice and Lightyear water bottle but
significantly this Trinity cube is not
for people who like to feel good oh no
it's for you because you understand that
when something is in order something
else is not